[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's brief video we're going to be
discussing none other than luna
looney lovegood more specifically we're
going to be discussing what happened to
luna
after the events of the deathly hallows
when the harry potter story ends
we're brought to the epilogue at
platform nine and three-quarters where
harry sends off his son to hogwarts
along with him we see ginny hermione ron
and
malfoy however there were plenty more
characters than that in the story
many of whom are fan favorites so i
think we deserve to know
what happened to some of these other
characters today
we're going to be discussing
specifically luna lovegood
and what came of the zany ravenclaw
student but first
let's start with the refresher luna's
character from the beginning of the
story
the girl gave off an aura of distinct
dottiness
perhaps it was the fact that she had
stuck her wand behind her left ear for
safekeeping
or that she had chosen to wear a
necklace of butter beer caps
or that she was reading a magazine
upside down
luna looney lovegood was born in the
year 1981
to father xenophilius and mother pandora
lovegood
she started at hogwarts one year after
harry potter in the year 1992
shout out to people born in 1992 and was
sorted into ravenclaw house
despite being a veritable oddball luna
was quite talented magically
most likely stemming from her
inquisitive nature in addition to that
she was massively intelligent and very
knowledgeable
in part due to the fact that she was so
open-minded though her presence in
social situations was a bit
peculiar luna knew a lot more about the
magical world than many gave her credit
for
and as a result she was a powerful young
witch she was raised primarily by her
father xenophilius
as her mother tragically died
experimenting with spells
when she was just nine however both of
her parents were
like her magically talented but
simultaneously
highly unusual in the series luna
becomes a close companion of the trio
and proves to be a valuable asset in
damodal's army where she quickly learns
how to produce a patronus
luna was truly one of harry's earliest
supporters believing everything he said
about voldemort's return
before many others would she also fought
valiantly in the battle against
voldemort and the death eaters
taking part in numerous skirmishes part
of what people came to love about luna
was that she was just so
luna she was so herself and never
allowed herself to change
while at first she was a bit of an
outcast due to this attitude
many eventually came to love her it
turns out later in life luna went on to
become a rather famous major zoologist
for those unfamiliar with the profession
a major zoologist is a wizard or witch
who studies magical creatures
this profession shouldn't come as a
surprise given that luna exhibited an
affinity for magical creatures
during the harry potter story properly
introducing harry to thestrals in the
order of the phoenix
the perhaps most notable major zoologist
is newt scamander
who wrote fantastic beasts and where to
find them interestingly enough
luna actually went on to marry rolf
scamander newt's grandson
it has been expressed for their wedding
luna dressed in typical
eccentric lunar fashion sporting a
rainbow dress
and tiara with unicorn horns later on
sometime between the years 2008 and 2014
the pair had two sons lorkhan and
lysander
as an adult luna remained close friends
with harry ron and hermione
in fact luna made such an impression on
harry that he named his daughter
lily luna after his mother and of course
luna
a true honor according to rowling luna
never changed
she remained her quirky lovable self
which is what i think we all hoped for
that's it for today's video who next let
me know in the comment section
below until next time i think i'll just
go down and have some pudding
and wait for it all to turn up it always
does in the end
you